Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
If you are new here, this is a series about
research with the name Two Minute Papers,
but let's be honest here.
It's never two minutes.
We are going to talk about two really cool
papers that help us create physically based
material models from photographs that we can
use in our light simulation programs.
Just as a note, these authors, Miika and Jaakko
have been on a rampage for years now and have
popped so many fantastic papers each of which
I was blown away by.
For instance, earlier, we talked about their
work on Gradient Domain Light Transport, brilliant
piece of work, I've put a link in the description
box, make sure to check it out!
So the problem we're trying to solve is very
simple to understand: the input is a photograph
of a given material somewhere in our vicinity,
and the output is a bona fide physical material
model that we can use in our photorealistic
rendering program.
We can import real world materials in our
virtual worlds, if you will.
Before we proceed, let's define a few mandatory
terms:
A material is diffuse if incoming light from
one direction is reflected equally in all
directions.
This means that they look the same from all
White walls and matte surfaces are excellent
examples of that.
A material we shall consider specular if incoming
light from one direction is reflected back
to one direction.
This means that if we turn our head a bit,
we will see something different.
For instance, the windshield of a car, water
and reflections in a mirror can be visualized
with a specular material model.
Of course, materials can also be a combination
of both.
For instance, car paint, our hair and skin
are all combinations of these material models.
Glossy materials are midway between the two
where the incoming light from one direction
is reflected to not everywhere equally, and
not in one direction, but a small selected
set of directions.
They change a bit when we move our head, but
not that much.
In the Two-Shot Capture paper, a material
model is given by how much light is reflected
and absorbed by the diffuse and specular components
of the material, and something that we call
a normal map, which captures the bumpiness
of the material.
Other factors like glossiness and anisotropy
are also recorded, but we shall focus on the
diffuse and the specular parts.
The authors ask us to grab our phone for two
photographs of a material to ensure a high-quality
reconstruction procedure: one with flash,
and one without.
And the question immediately arises: why two
images?
Well, the image without flash can capture
the component that looks the same from all
directions, this is the diffuse component,
and the photograph with flash can capture
the specular component because we can see
how the material handles specular reflections.
And it is needless to say, the presented results
are absolutely fantastic.
So, first paper, two images, one material
model.
And therein lies the problem, which they tried
to address in the second paper.
If a computer looks at such an image, it doesn't
know which part of one photograph is the diffuse
and which is the specular reflection.
However, I remember sitting in the waiting
room of a hospital while reading the first
paper, and this waiting room had a tiled glossy
wall, and I was thinking that one image should
be enough, because if I look at something,
I can easily discern what the diffuse colors
are, and which part is the specular reflection
of something else.
I don't need multiple photographs for that.
I can also immediately see how bumpy it is,
even from one photograph, I don't need to
turn my head around.
This is because we, humans have not a mathematical,
but an intuitive understanding of the materials
we see around us.
So can we explain the same kind of understanding
of materials to a computer somehow?
Can we do it with only one image?
And the answer is, yes we can, and, hopefully,
we already feel the alluring call of neural
networks.
We can get a neural network that was trained
on a lot of different images to try to guess
what these material reflectance parameters
should look like.
However, the output should not be one image,
but multiple images with the diffuse and specular
reflectance informations, and a normal map
to describe the bumpiness of this surface.
Merely throwing a neural network at this problem,
is however, not sufficient.
There needs to be some kind of conspiracy
between these images, because real materials
are not arbitrarily put together.
If one of these images is smooth, or has interesting
features somewhere, the others have to follow
it in some way.
This "some way" is mathematically quite challenging
to formulate, which is a really cool part
of the paper.
This conspiracy part is a bit like if we had
4 criminals testifying at a trial, where they
try to sell their lies, and to maintain the
credibility of their made up story, they have
previously had to synchronize their lies so
they line up correctly.
The paper contains neat tricks to control
the output of the neural network and create
these conspiracies across these multiple image
outputs that yield a valid and believable
material model.
And the results, are again, just fantastic.
Second paper, one image, one material model.
It doesn't get any better than that.
Spectacular, not specular...spectacular piece
of work.
The first paper is great, but the second is
smoking hot, by all that is holy, I am getting
goosebumps.
If you are interested in hearing a bit more
about light transport and are not afraid of
some mathematics, we recently recorded my
full course on this at the Technical University
of Vienna, the entirety of which is freely
available for everyone.
There is a link for it in the video description
box, make sure to check it out!
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!